avec nous le ministre responsable de la
réforme sinon j'allais barrette monsieur
j'en ai marre est bonsoir monsieur roy
alors on va prendre des exemples de
notre vie je vais le prendre de façon là
la façon la main le plus concrètes
possible pour que les gens comprennent
vous qu'est ce que vous voulez aller
dans les commerces
tous ces gens qui se plaignait dans la
région de montréal par exemple que dans
certains commerces était difficile de se
faire servir en français
qu'est-ce que ça va changer cette
réforme
plusieurs choses la première des choses
c'est que c'est pas normal que les
québécois lorsqu'il pénètre dans un
commerce sur l'île de montréal notamment
qu'ils puissent pas se faire servir dans
leur langue en français donc on garantit
le droit d'être servis et informer en
français on a ces droits là existent
pour ça signifie que désormais les
québécois et les québécoises pourront
déposer une plainte à l'occuper l'efs et
l'oculaire accompagnera les entreprises
et ultime ça fait quoi l'enfant excusez
moi je traduis pour les gens oui le fisc
québécois la française et ultime mais il
pourrait y avoir une sanction pénale si
jamais le commerçant l'entreprise ne se
conformait pas aux droits d'être servis
en français est informé en français on
agit également sur la langue de travail
dans l'intérieur des commerces des
organisations on veut s'assurer que les
québécois puissent travailler en
français donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
modifié l'article 46 la charte de la
langue française il va faire en sorte
qu'un employeur ne pourra plus exiger
une connaissance de nombreux autres que
le français à moins que ce soit
nécessaire et qu'il a pris tous les
moyens raisonnables pour éviter d'
exiger telle langue
à titre d'exemple l'anglais et on vient
aussi permettre aux travailleurs qui
verraient leurs droits bafoués de
travailler en français d'avoir recours
notamment par le biais de la commission
des normes du travail
alors on agit sur la langue de travail
et surtout sur la langue d'intégration
parce qu'un des éléments les plus
importants sur lesquels on agisse la
création de francisation québec pour
faire en sorte d'intégrer en français
les personnes immigrantes oui je vis un
prix parce que c'est vous avez raison
c'est ce volet important je vous en
ferai mais je reste dans le commerce
donc si moi je m'aperçois que je
progresse de me faire servir en français
elle magasin ou tel autre c'est moi
c'est à la charge du client donc du
citoyen d'appeler le fisc québécois la
langue français de faire plus que je
pouvais faire ça déjà aujourd'hui non
non mais actuellement il n'y avait pas
de recours vous pouviez faire une
plainte à l'office québécois de la
langue française le cul élèves pouvaient
appeler mais il n'y avait pas vraiment
de traitement de ces plaintes le
désormais les droits seront exécutoires
le cul et l'efs accompagnera
l'entreprise et ultime si l'entreprise
ne se conforme pas il ya plus lourde
ordonnance de l'eau qu elle ait fait
s'il n'est pas respecté
il pourra y avoir une sanction pénale à
rattacher à ça même chose également les
citoyens pourront faire respecter leurs
droits devant les tribunaux dont il
pourrait y avoir une pour cette paix
civile la part des citoyens s'ils
étaient le faire et donc vous savez ça
fait partie des droits fondamentaux qui
avait été créée en 1977 comme ceux dans
la charte des droits et libertés de la
personne par contre il n'avait pas de
caractère exécutoire alors ça c'est un
changement important pour faire en sorte
qu'ils aient changé passant par dans les
commerces normal qu'au centre bell
on se pose sa saveur en français donc ça
devient droit ou chez important que les
droits reconnus dans la charte
québécoise où elle est nommée de la
charte canadienne des droits le droit de
se faire servir en français oui le droit
également d'avoir une législation en
justice en français le droit de vivre en
français également donc ça c'est des
droits fondamentaux qui ont été créée en
1967 et nous on s'assure de multiplier
cet exutoire
l'objectif de la loi 101 puis vous
l'avez rappelé en conférence de presse
c'était que le transfert linguistique
les immigrants se fasse vers le français
j'avais donné de chiffres que je vais
montrer aux gens forts intéressants en
1977 donc année 1 de la loi 101 il y
avait 25 % seulement des immigrants qui
choisissent elles français aujourd'hui
on est à 53 % donc il ya eu une
amélioration de la loi 101 en rendant
l'école obligatoire au primaire ou
secondaire fait que le plus d'immigrants
qui choisissent le français quelle
mesure vous annoncer aujourd'hui qui va
permettre d'aller au delà du 53 pour ça
parce que beaucoup d'experts qui disent
fois arrivé à 60 70 semaines 80%
et même je vous dirais 90 % parce que le
taux de transfert linguistique dans le
reste du canada et de 99% vers l'anglais
alors tous les démographes disent qu'on
doit atteindre un taux de 90% pour
assurer la pérennité de la langue alors
ce qu'on fait c'est contré francisation
québec un guichet unique au sein du
ministère de l'immigration pour les
cours de francisation mais surtout on va
s'assurer avec francisation québec de
pouvoir francisé directement en
entreprise
l'état québécois également et il va
devenir exemplaire donc les
communications avec les taux vont être
exclusivement français désormais avec
les nouveaux arrivants
il faut faire ce qui n'était pas le cas
dans le x y avait un bilinguisme
institutionnel au sein de l'état
québécois et on y met fin
le tout tout tout en s'assurant de
respecter les droits de la communauté
anglophone qui peuvent bénéficier des
services en anglais ce je me suis
assurée lorsque j'ai préparé le projet
de loi de protéger le roi de la
communauté anglo mais je savais que le
guichet unique est ce que ça va faire en
sorte qu'ils vont avoir dans les faits
plus de cours de francisation dans les
faits nos wii déjà lorsque j'étais
ministre l'immigration on avait élargi
l'offre de cours ou aux migrants qui
sont en situation temporaire on avait
créé des allocations également la
première année que j'étais là en 2018
le nombre d'inscriptions bondi de 25%
avec les mesures qu'on avait mis en
place dont vous continuez de le faire
également
et oui il faut être dans toutes les
entreprises où il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas la maîtrise de langue française pour
offrir ces services là justement pour
que dans le milieu vous savez les deux
facteurs d'intégration des plus
importantes sociétés c'est le fait
d'occuper un emploi
il fait de partager la langue commune
alors au québec la langue quand même si
le français ou l'affirmé haut et fort il
faut surtout prendre les outils pour
faire en sorte de franciser les
personnes qui choisissent le québec est
d'éviter qu'elles migrent vers le côté
de la langue anglaise d'utilisation
d'alan à l'aise et ça va être très clair
désormais pour l'état québécois eux
c'est en français que ça se passe et que
la langue commune québec cette fois
c'est l'éducation
évidemment est un vecteur extrêmement
important dans l'intégration d'une
communauté francophone ou communauté
anglophone pas pour rien que la loi 101
était le coeur de dire que obliger les
enfants d'immigrants d'aller à l'école
française beaucoup de gens vous les
entendez vous disais il faut que le
sujet fasse partie de ce chapeau là il
faut que obliger les les gens continuent
et en français et interdire ou
francophones d'aller étudier en anglais
au sujet vous avez décidé de plafonner
le pourcentage actuel d'étudiants
francophones dans un cégep anglophone
qu'est-ce que ça va changer puisque dans
le fond il ya le pourcentage est assez
élevé de francophones actuellement non
ça change quoi de faire ça et
effectivement on a plafonné safran sorte
que jamais le réseau anglophone vont
pouvoir accéder d'ici le 5 % des places
dans le réseau collégial total on
voulait permettre aux francophones et
aux allophones qui sont assujetties à la
loi 101 d'avoir le libre choix de
pouvoir s'ils le souhaitent poursuivre
leur parcours scolaire au collégial en
anglais c'est le libre-choix cependant
la langue normale des études supérieures
demeure le français alors dans le projet
de loi j'ai instauré une épreuve
uniforme de français au réseau collégial
anglophone comme c'est le feu dans le
réseau collégial francophone donc
maintenant pour diplômés si un
francophone décide dans le résultat les
étudier au cégep dans le réseau
anglophone va devoir passer la même
évaluation que s'il avait été dans le
réseau anglophone
également on priorise également dans les
collèges dans les cégeps anglophones les
la communauté anglophone donc les ayants
droit qui vont avoir priorité pour
pouvoir accéder mais la proportion
actuelle de francophones dans les cégeps
anglophones qui était jugé trop élevé
par certains avouent restée la même
autrement t elle pas nécessairement
parce que c'est la priorité va être
donnée aux membres de la communauté
anglophone est certain
parfois se voyait refuser l'accès à des
études collégiales en anglais parce que
leur moyenne assez élevé pour entrer
dans un cégep comme darwin
donc nous ce qu'on veut pas c'est
vraiment s'assurer que les gens
choisissent où le revenu entre phone et
je crois aussi que comme société il faut
avoir une réflexion par rapport à la
langue normale des études on doit
poursuivre en france au québec on doit
pouvoir étudier au primaire au
secondaire au cégep et lemercier et
gagner sa vie en france est aussi sur le
marché du travail il faut il faut le
dire là c'est pas nécessaire de gagner
sa vie en anglais on peut très bien
réussir en utilisant notre langue
nationale vous est ce que je me trompe
vous vous seriez allé plus loin pour le
sujet je riais aller à l'application de
la loi 101 au cégep
écoutez ce que dans le projet de loi
c'est la position du gouvernement qui
ont un consensus qui fait en sorte
vraiment avoir une mesure qui va avoir
une influence sur le français comme
langue commune et j'en suis très fier ok
alors interminable cheminée où
j'espérais avez vous ciblez ce que vous
espérez autrement dit tout ce bouquet de
mesures va faire en sorte d'après-vous
de freiner le lent déclin du français
oui tout à fait écouter on agit sur
plusieurs fronts langue du commerce
langue des affaires langue des études
langue d'intégration des personnes ni g
on vient c'est réussi dans la
constitution que les québécois et les
québécoises forment une nation qui la
langue officielle et commune québec si
le français
alors on a plusieurs moyens mon collègue
des finances m'a confié 100 millions de
dollars pour les cinq prochaines années
aucun mur langue française puis ça je
pense que c'est un plan trop tôt je leur
ai dit monsieur roy il ya de cela
plusieurs mois je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la démonstration qu'on a un plan
costaud pour la langue française
merci monsieur le ministre on se
reparlera va suivre ça parce que
j'allais lancer des consultations puis
on n'a pas fini d'en parler à l'automne
notamment merci beaucoup
les modules à vous au revoir